okay this is a very interesting story
and there's a couple different elements
to it which I want to talk about to kind
of set the stage many of you know that
there's currently a crisis in Venezuela
and it involves the despotic
authoritarian autocrat Nicolas Maduro
and as a principled progressive I want
the United States to stay absolutely out
of Venezuela and I also want Nicolas
Maduro to go who has ravaged the country
and I want an actual democratic leader
not a puppet of the United States to
come to power and to start working on
the difficult problems that Venezuela
has to solve for itself that's my view
because I'm a progressive but in the
middle of all of this there are lots of
politics to be sorted out and one of
those elements relates to American
companies doing business with the Maduro
regime it relates to hypocrisy zuv
individual American elected officials
there are all sorts of other political
issues that are that are in the mix here
the geopolitical implications of
Russia's perspective on what's going on
in Venezuela the Cuban component and the
possible legality or illegality of Cuban
involvement in Venezuela for a long time
which is another issue that there's some
really smart pieces out there that I
recommend you read but in a totally sort
of stunning but also not altogether
surprising revelation given that Trump
is involved with all sorts of dirty
players the Miami Herald is now
reporting that Donald Trump's company
sold a luxury property in the Dominican
Republic to a shell company apparently
tied to the Nicolas Maduro regime of
Venezuela and specifically who we're
talking about is the second most
powerful person in the Maduro government
his name is Diosdado Cabello Kibeho or
as we would say in argentina cabeza who
is under US sanctions personally for
allegedly trafficking drugs and
laundering money now I will make it
abundantly clear it's not believed that
this transaction would rise to the level
of criminality because it allegedly took
place in 2015 when this individual
was not yet under sanctions but I don't
even actually care so much about the
brazen double standards uh you know
understand that Trump considers meddling
in Venezuela against the Maduro regime
as president and just years ago he was
selling property to people associated
with the Maduro regime were accustomed
to the double standards there is
countless there is boundless hypocrisy
it's sort of pedestrian and boring at
this point and we know that Republicans
and trumpets don't care about the
hypocrisy and double standards of Donald
Trump so it's like barely even worth
discussing the story here is that this
is not rare what I mean by that is
Donald Trump is involved in all sorts of
sketchy financial transactions presumed
money laundering of all kinds for many
for individuals in countries that are
under sanction at this point in time so
remember the Trump Organization
participated in what they appear to have
known was a money laundering operation
involving a branch of the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard that worked on
getting components for weapons of mass
destruction so again Trump Iran is
terrible even though they didn't
actually violate any of the provisions
of the Iran deal that they signed with
President Obama were out of the Iran
deal screw Iran but Trump's organization
reportedly involved in a
money-laundering scheme for the people
who are obtaining or working to obtain
and develop weapons of mass destruction
in Iran total blatant hypocrisy also not
rare Trump has done this before there's
an article in The New Yorker from two
years ago called Donald Trump's worse
deal which outlines a lot of the comings
and goings of that Iranian National
Guard a Revolutionary Guard fiasco there
are endless projects where Trump and his
kids have misled buyers about real
estate deals look for example at the Pro
Publica article from 2018 called here
the Trump projects were Ivanka and her
dad mislead buyers this is a scam stir
criminal who is in the White House so of
course there are dozens of stories like
this and it's not surprising that it
involves Russian oligarchs tied to Putin
as I told you earlier in the
program it involves the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard and now it
reportedly involves Nicolas maduro's
number two net number two guy we could
go even further I could talk to you in
detail and I think maybe we have
discussed this on the program about the
fiasco in Baku Azerbaijan which we could
do an entire show about what went on
with Trump's dealings there Trump has
likely been a criminal as long as he's
been a player in New York and World real
estate and if there's anything good that
comes from the Donald Trump presidency
because it's basically all bad it would
be that maybe it will expose the level
of criminality that Donald Trump's
business has been involved in and if
we're lucky it doesn't seem like this is
definitely going to be the case but if
we're lucky maybe all of these
investigations and revelations that come
from the spotlight being on Donald Trump
as president of the United States maybe
it will let us pierce the kleptocracy of
that that Donald Trump and the people
around him have perpetuated and maybe
somebody will be held accountable at
some point for for some small piece of
these misdeeds that again are not rare
in the sense that it's not just Trump
that does this stuff most of the people
that do the shady business that Trump
has been doing for decades are sort of
smart enough quite frankly to realize
that running for elected office running
for anything where there would be an
expectation that you would disclose your
full finances where there would be a
spotlight and a micro a magnifying glass
placed on what you've been doing in
business and professionally most
super-rich dudes like Trump recognize
they shouldn't go anywhere near politics
because this is exactly the type of
thing that could happen we've got an
opportunity now with Donald Trump to
actually hold one of these sort of
gilded families accountable for stuff
that tons of rich dudes and gals are
doing and have been doing and almost
always are not held accountable for make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
while you're there follow me i'm on
instagram at david pakman we'll take a
quick break and we have so much more
still upcoming on today